.
>> IT HAS PROVEN
DRUG CAN BLOCK
epER OF REMDEVISUSUA COVID-19.
>>HE DAT SREMDESIVIR HAS A R- I
VER.
TH QUITE PORTANT. TS  A
INTUDIES TOUTEY ED MORTALITY AN.
>> THIS S AVE
PHYSNS PROBABLY BERE HAD
CHOM S HA OICES.
>> FOR AN AIV IN A V ME I VERYGS
UNWLAOREOPEN, TE DIRE W DR. FAU.
>> IT IS MOREIK NOT
THAT WE WILL SEE AGAINAIN U S
NAIL IN THE COFFIN OF
>> Reporter: PFIZE TESTING IN TE
IT COULD
PP MILLIONS BY TF
E  UNIVERSITY IN TS LASTOF OWNV.
FLORIDA'S E
TO CLOSE, J UNVEILED PLAN
TO >> ANY MOR W OW APPEAR STATM
THE E AIS ELINEST FOR A
DOWNWARD TRAJECTOR CASES WITHINY
PE ANYREOPENING.EADY ALLOWED IN
LO A TOL
STILL MY A GOVERNOR
NOW FEELING PRESSETHOSEIER OPEN.
THERE'S NO QUESTION IT PUTS SU.
LYING TO SUGGE
ORRIED ALL THER SHOER MA
AMS ALSOIDEA FOR PEO TURO
WORKURNDE BE G
YET. HOPE THERE'S FBASEBAAN THE
TH.r:0 JUST
ATTENDED THE FUNERAL OF A RABBIR
12E ISSD
VIIN DCITY'S CALLED OHE JEWISH
TWITTEAN
>> I REGRET IF THEAY ID WAY GAV.
ASAID WITHS
FRUSTRATION.
>> Rep
CITE WHITEOU
4.
WEE Y AR  WE
HAFACT JUST PASSED TNING AND SA
IT O TREATANHI
XTRAORDINARYSEION FROM THE F WOD
BEY.BUREDIMES, AND THE FDA TEL .
KWATT
YOU SO MUC IS CHIEF
MEDICAL CSPONNTA.SANJAY, DR.
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT REMDESIVIR.
WHAT'S YOUR READ ON IT?
>> YEAH, HE DID.THINK MY READ I,
N WAITING TRIALLLY IS A RL GROU.
MOST OF THEEP THAT'S  OUT THERE
RAND
THIS WAS WELL-CONDUCTED TR68 CE.
WHGNIFICANCE AND WHAHI
REALLY DOES,T' T
LOOK AT THE OUTCO
LOOKING .
THEY WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
BETWEEN THE PLACE EVE
DOUGH.
THAT'S SIGNIFICANT
FINDING.
IT'S HARD TO SAYTP
DUO THE DI GIVEN THE
BUT ING ON THE RIGHT, THE
DURATION OF ILLNESS, THAT ISTHEO
PATIENTS WHO GOT
THAT -- YOU KNOW, T  SIGNIFICAS
OF CONCEPT THAT
THIS SEEMS TO HAVET ON  JAKETHIS
E
THIS IS THE FIR T SHOW
THAT IMPACT. TSAN
TO BE SOINO FIND DUNTUS YOUR NOT
BECAE IF IT DOES THAT, AS YOU
KNOW,AKE, O FEELING
BETTER, THAT MIGHT DECREASE THEA
BIGL.
THAT YETTHBECAUSE, AS
LARRY BRINT IT'S
ON TTH>>TENTIALLY GOOD NEWS
TH COMMISSIONER
UN PRESI
GOTTLIEB, SAID, QUOTE, THE DATA
IS ENOUGH SRT
ER AUTHORIZA FTHE FDA.
WH HHAT EMERGENCY
AUTHORIZATION GOES FORWARD?
AS NICK WASUS SAYING,EY HAV
SURE THEY CAN START TO
PRHIS MEA MEDICATIAI'S BEEN AROR
IT WAS TRIALED IN EBOLA
SO IT IS ANSTGDRUG.S TO BE A QU
C GOING
TO COME.
I SHOULD POI THISOW ,
EMERGENCY  ION,
E' LOWER BAR FY THAIN THE MIDDL.
SO I'M NOT SURPRISEDL IT RT OF .
TALKED SCOTT GOTTL
HOUR AGO AS WELL , ANDOF THE QU
Y HADHE ANDH BECAUSE OF SOMXISTN
THEY PROBABLY WILL BE THE O  MA
TO BENEFIT FROIS L
A
FCIPARED IT TO THE HAD WHET HE
CRIS
>>EAH, HEARDTHAT, AND I WAS
SURPRISEDTHAT.
YOU KN, THE DATA OF WHAT IDOTHE
MORTALY,VES.
ITOEEN THE
DURATION OF ILLNESS, AND THAT
COUL S
OUTAMIFLU, EVEN,
SS I
IT N
ACTU DE MOR WE'LLAVNDIT'S AGAIN,
DRUG.
THIS IS A DRUG THAT ALREADY
EXISTED, THAT'S BEISEDFOR THIS T
COROVIVIOUSLS 40YEARS, HE HAS
CONT F SORT OF
THD DATA,
WE'LL PUT IT UP WEBE LOOIS
EM SA,RO O
DEATHOLL W OTS APRONS. PTHTOLL
GET THERE UNTIL AU. IT AND IT'S.
WHAT'S GOING , I T AND I HAD A
NVS A COUPLE
OF WEEO.
YOU SAID IS IT LIKELY W TO THIS.
AND AS YOU KNOHA MODELTHAT PREDE
FRAN A
YOU LOOK AT THE NUM
PUT  WIDE GIVE A WIDEE OF NUMB
30  IN SOME OF THESE
RANGES HEREINK ITDIULRE'STWO THT
ONE IS THAT WEINCLUDBL INFECTIO
OBABLES AND
AB WITH REGARD T OVID INFECTION.
OBVIOUSLY THE PAU THAT
SEEING IS MOR A EAU,  AT A HI
UP, IT' UP FOR A WHILE,
WEEHAEXT,HOPEFULLY IT WILL STAR
FINALLY, JAKE, T  ORDERS THAT AE
GEGON'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S ALREADY HAD AN, I D.
THAT'S P THE REASON
PROJECTED DEATHS NOW BY AUGUST
ARE GOING TO GO UP.LO EVEN ,0, S
ON WHAT WE'RE SEEING R